if you want to become a billionaire
impact a billion people and the
realization I have is that a thousand
years ago the only people who could
impact a nation or a region were the
kings and the queens they only and at
best they could deploy their troops a
hundred years ago it was the
industrialist the robber barons who
could build the railroads the steel
mills and affect the economy of a region
or solve problems today it's all of us
anyone who is passionate and driven by a
dream and who wants to solve a problem
can because we have access to
extraordinary capabilities that only the
largest government and corporations had
twenty years ago and so we're living in
a very different day and age a day and
age where we can stop complaining about
problems and start solving problems and
that truly gives me the greatest hope
for where we're going
you